it's crazy because it's kind of
Bittersweet where it's like I've seen
her grow as a businesswoman and then
like the skill set that she's been able
to acquire and the person that she
became that you're like oh wow it's
almost as if like you see someone get
the black belt and you're like wow it's
gonna be crazy from here and then she's
like you know what I don't really like
Jiu Jitsu and then you're like what
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to another great episode of
careful boys today we have with us a
lovely Geo in Twitter
disease like a very progression type of
uh letter is it because it's the Asian
but is it like Asian you know you guys
nah this is like hip-hop you know boys
in the hood the Z makes us edgy he
sounds a lot cooler than I remember that
was tight yeah what you talking about
huh yeah yeah now he's real cool even
cooler hi Geo hi thanks for coming
thanks for bringing me back wow it comes
like once a year I think I do that's our
relationship I come once a year
to get here nothing he never invites me
actually I invited myself wait what do
you mind
how does it fight you what the [__] when
was the last time you invited me at
least once a month
Mark's got a stiff neck if you haven't
noticed it's the worst thing ever we're
gonna talk about it every video though I
I've almost [__] every month though
that when you when you are gonna come I
go you want to jump on JK news and
you're usually busy or doing something
okay that sounds like it might be a
conversation going on in your head but
this time around I was like I even asked
you to bring tiger today remember that
oh that would have been great see yeah I
always tried to always try we need a
part two with Tycoon I know that's what
I told her this was five now no I just
feel like I don't believe Bart that much
what the [__]
why don't you believe because I feel
like we always want GOI how come you
don't believe me
because you seem tense
I always ask whenever she's coming when
she comes I go you wanna but then she's
probably usually busy every time bar
lies he pulls his neck right yeah I
remember that one time that who did a
whole JK news with a neck bracelet did
you really he looks so stupid it was so
fun yeah you should get it yeah I think
you need it no but it's not my neck this
time it's like my my [__] rhomboid or
some [__] wrong boy
was in wrong boy what's a wrong boy I
think that's what it's called it's like
it's like part of her like it's between
your scapulas between US capture that's
your shoulders again yeah yeah
that's like the adult version of someone
going but like in the kitchen yeah
and you just respect them so much more
it could be glute media I didn't know
you were such an academic I know just
say you're back or something dude what
happened again to your neck or you're
sorry Robert oh is this [__] I was
just I was just working out this morning
and then um you know like sometimes you
get to like the extra reps do you know
what he's talking about will you work
out to failure like yeah you're just
trying to like get an extra rep or to it
nothing crazy but then I should have
known since I've been Lifting for so
long like I should have known if I've
been on a bunch of planes and hotels my
body's probably misaligned oh and then
so I should probably like the first week
or two back I should just like cut it
short a little bit especially since I'm
[__] old geezer but then but then
today I was like oh what feels good I
got a good warm-up in and then literally
like this much from completion just from
here to like oh okay
[Laughter]
yeah
the guy next time goes oh happy birthday
the guy next to him's like did you hear
he did 38 reps that's [__] crazy this
guy is strong yeah I was just working
this much away ah
[__] [__] that'll do it huh yeah
that'll do it hey sorry you're that bad
that sucks yeah are you really sorry
yeah because he loves working out oh
you're nice Scott what a nice I know and
you know what a pretty prevent prevented
me from doing I was like oh cool I got
extra 20 30 minutes today I haven't hit
the bag in a while I'm gonna go hit the
bag and then I I get gloves I go up
there and I go ow
I like how he hits with his lip and it's
[__] right I'm like ah [__] I
couldn't I had an extra 20 minutes to do
cardio and also I just ended up like uh
jogging around the city but I was like
oh cool I've hit the back and while I'll
do 20 minutes of the [__] backwards I
wish she was doing this around people so
that like experts observe you would be
like he's Shadow Boxing imaginary
opponent at this moment um
oh
Mr rhomboid method boxing method boxing
yeah dude oh man so how you doing Jill
I'm chilling it's good to be back how's
your run boy my rhomboids are good
what's what is that Joe yeah that's a
lot of sugar that I took out that's a
lot it looks like like a crappy like
children's project
we're gonna put on the fridge oh don't
throw it away
it's a lot of sugar he said it's a good
good roll into the warm-ups huh so back
to Geo how's your how's life as a
entrepreneur
it's hard it's definitely hard there's a
lot there's like a lot of Shifting that
has to happen you know because like if
your work mode you want to just get
you're like task oriented right so you
want to get [__] done and you want to
just explain it a to [__] Z and do it
get it done but then now when it's like
kid mode you have to like tone it all
down and be like a little bit more fluid
and understanding and patient you're
just like [__]
um so it's uh it's challenging for sure
are you naturally more A to Z or
naturally more fluid like uh even in
your younger self if you will pre-type
us so to speak
um I'm naturally more fluid that means
scatter brains
is that what that means oh we're getting
a lot of scientific terms for the things
people are saying that means yeah yeah
just how fast you turn dude
the diagnosis
afraid you're just scatter brains oh I
don't diagnose you with scatter brains
look to the left with the right
see it right in there I [__] thought
so
that's this whole show right now this is
all scatterbrained well yeah I mean
you're combining two things that are
hard on their own yeah yeah it's pretty
it's pretty opposite and it simplifies
it so easily well having a kid is pretty
hard having a business is pretty hard so
don't Anthony it's gonna be hard being a
moment that's a doll Anthony
and when like he asked it he repurposed
it as an assaulted him
I'm seven minutes I have no idea what
the [__] this video can you imagine me
me talking to Geo making you eye contact
so duh Anthony
come on don't ask questions like that
Anthony
laughs
but it does it really does feel like I
haven't missed a beat man like I haven't
been on in like I don't know [__] a
year two years you haven't grown at all
huh we haven't learned [__] you guys
have a really cool chemistry and stuff
but like coming back in Joe's still
interrupting still all over the place
Bart's still talking all sorts of [__]
you're really nice like you got you got
your [__] all organized it's really cool
you two are I mean you're way better
than I was what do you mean uh in that
chair that was my chair dude that looks
like that I don't think I don't think I
I do the duties of Geo junto uh
Antoinette you said it was jinto before
when she got her hair blonde she became
yeah
hey the J silent yeah yeah he does Nick
does a better job because you never gave
bar hand jobs under the table yep you
don't why don't you do that no he does
do that you don't do that oh Anthony
good I appreciate it that's why I got
the seat good I'm happy I'm happy my
work is is done he comes home he's
satisfied he's just sleepy all the time
that's why he's driving so low when he
gets old and Bart uses Nick as a as a as
an example when he's trying to show the
world I guess I'm just the the room's
[__] sex toy I guess yes
yeah thanks dude how's it Anthony knows
what I'm talking about do you um do you
enjoy being a moment how'd you say you
said
entrepreneur
is it
something like that yeah do I enjoy it
yeah do you enjoy it no I don't I don't
like it how would you how would you love
like what's your dream way of adjusting
it to where it would work perfectly
she's like Bart needs to do more
I have a I have a partner because that's
kind of the next like goal right is to
kind of make it so that Geo can be a
stay-at-home mom and things kind of run
a lot more autonomously in sometimes
yeah I got really
got like I have a really good grasp on
business and I really understand it but
now that I really get it I'm like yeah
this is not this is not my cup of tea I
really do like you know the family life
and and being with taika and that's been
a lot of fun it's crazy because it's
kind of Bittersweet where it's like I've
seen her grow as a businesswoman and
then like the skill set that she's been
able to acquire and the person that she
became that you're like oh wow it's
almost as if like you see someone get
the black belt and they're like wow it's
gonna be crazy from here and then she's
like you know what I don't really like
Jiu Jitsu and then you're like what
it was like that but I get it I know
what her true passion is right and I've
said that since day since day one like
before we even got like when we first
got together I was like no matter what
as soon as I have a kid I'm not working
but I mean it didn't go to plan but but
since the beginning so basically at
white belt you're like I don't like Jiu
Jitsu I still got a black belt though
yeah that's what's cool like I think
when people say like oh this isn't my
cup of tea after they've successfully
achieved something that counts a lot
more than someone who's like kind of not
doing well they're like I don't like
this yeah yeah it's like trying with
food yeah yeah that's like you stupid as
[__] you're like school's not for me
like excuses so you just don't want to
go
yeah but then I know School wasn't for
me but [__] I finished it he smart said
something cool about you on a past
episode are you trying to get a hand job
are you trying to like maybe
his next crew could give his hands still
straight all right I don't know if it's
up yet but he said uh yeah he said
um oh man in the beginning when we were
starting the business I wasn't sure how
it would go but after doing barbell with
Geo I I would never do another business
without her that's what he said better
say that [__] never say that but then at
the end he went
[Laughter]
no it is really cool he's been a really
cool partner to have uh just because
we're so opposite like he's super
creative that's the best and I'm sure
like he's like CEO and I'm more like CEO
where I'm like the organized one even
though I have I've been diagnosed with
scatterbrains
um so let's go
[Laughter]
yeah so we both complement each other
really really well and and I mean we've
been together for 15 years and we've
done business this whole time
um so we really it's it's really
harmonious when we get to work together
yeah that's the best when you're
opposites you cover way more ground that
way you don't butt heads on things that
you have different methods for yeah
totally works it's been pretty tight
what do you butt heads on when it comes
to the business nowadays
not anything anymore but I think in the
beginning it was more so bumping heads
on uh uh you know both of us thinking
that we're like the creative side of
things or like that
I mean we kind of share our hats but
then now we know where we lie yeah I
mean he's just a really good partner
because he'll just respect the position
so like we didn't really ever bump heads
did we bump heads it's been a long time
too I don't know I don't really remember
bumping heads because he's just such a
good like he's he's just a good partner
like in anything that he gets into he he
like understands his role and he plays
his video with you
I mean with Joe too it seems like you
guys hello you guys have been doing this
for how many goddamn years you know what
I mean I've never seen to work with too
yeah so I think there's just a lot of
respect so like the bumping heads is it
more so came trying to figure out like
the intimate relationship versus like
that balance was hard that one is where
the bumpy like when when did the note
like turn the clothes sign on the
business and then now it's it's
relationship time versus 10 o'clock at
night and we're doing relationship
things like being all cuddly on and
watching [__] TV but Spider-Man too
but we're actually yeah but we're
actually still in business mode and
talking very logical about [__] you know
yeah they've been pretty professional
though even though we're very
unprofessional on the surface like where
um they never what I'm thankful for is
that they never let their personal [__]
bleed in really deep into JK where like
other people will have full-blown
arguments in front of us or whatever
that's good contact like for them that
is good content they would fight and
then none of us would know that they're
actually fighting and we're still doing
JK news getting it done you know what JK
sometimes you're like you and Steve look
at each other and you're like
you guys go take a shot me and her go
and we keep fighting and then I'm Gonna
Roll and come back in
like we know exactly we stopped on the
fight come back outside
I think you guys should fight more on
camera I think you guys should hash it
out I know I think that's why it hasn't
gone viral that would have been that
would have been great content yeah
looking back is there anything you guys
want to hash out right now
you want a jury for yourself whatever
issues you have yeah we'll be impartial
what's some stuff that he does where he
just leaves cabinets open at home like
yeah something trivial yeah yeah yeah
and then it goes deep and then it goes
that one [__] time you wouldn't even
look at me and [__] yeah
for sure that sounds like of course we
were at the party you kept looking at
him at the party that's definitely bar
he's a party animal yeah he loves it
he had bigger muscles
and he lifted more
once again Bart yeah yeah yeah is um so
being back here and seeing like episodes
and stuff what do you feel like
got better about JK
what got better yeah like literally
because you know everything about it you
know like I think I think the hosts the
hosts got better I think like the the
the people coming in got better
um your guys's chemistry is really
really good I think my chemistry is
really good okay I like how
play around whereas before it would feel
like there was a lot of reasons distance
um just like in the group it just felt
like you couldn't say certain things and
like you just kind of felt like
uncomfortable to just really just go
like go go and just play imagination you
know
um where now it just feels like I was
telling bar I forgot the last time I
came I'm like dude I don't even want to
come back like your guys's chemistry is
so good whatever you say that the first
time that I I was here when you were
here you were like oh man just watching
you guys yeah I just felt like dude I am
not contributing [__] to this circle and
I don't want to like mess this up
because it's just it's not true so yo yo
come on that's not true dude Oh I
thought you said that's so true that's
so true yeah yeah
why are you here I do feel like I'm
holding back right now yeah
[Laughter]
favorite movie Rush Hour and in his his
bleach he goes yeah the Asian dude
that's running the whole [__] movie
this is a huge issue
[Laughter]
go get my toilet paper
so Jojo
but yeah that's what it feels like the
cool thing though is that the dynamic is
the same Dynamic that we've always had
even just as friends before I even was
even here yeah yeah absolutely which is
cool to like Super Rad yeah because like
it like we had that individually right
but I never saw your guys's chemistry
nobody knew who this guy was like this
guy just they still don't know we still
barely know he's still we're still
trying to get him to talk about himself
I thought you guys stop all the time
Master deflectors I don't like this
Narrative of me being a deflector you
are what that means it took us like six
months to get one story out of you that
was personal this guy like I I tell you
guys stuff yeah it's hard he has this
rule where like the first two responses
are sarcastic and then the third one's
real I
thought King right you were grumpy
exactly because why would I ever
prom kid he's like and I'm like
deflector now we got demonetized thank
you dude I can't do a jack off sign why
is that why is that a point of Pride
dude that's some high school no it's
just interesting it's a good story this
is interesting tell the damn details we
want to know the story
hey my name is Nick Dunn 10 years ago I
was a [__] prom cake
[Applause]
[Laughter]
with thumbs up I'm gonna go back to old
videos and try to see if times something
was said and it triggered him wanting to
say it and he couldn't
oh so Charles is the new king and he
goes
he's like he's like
or he's like there must be there must be
a lot of pressure I think I know how
that feels
and quitting the Royal Family
that's why he's always like yeah I
watched that documentary uh you what's
up about Mega Marble it's a lot of
pressure for them okay that's why he's
always asking so who's your favorite
Royal you guys
he actually asks that a lot he goes yeah
so in the royal family who's your
favorite one Prince Andrew's my favorite
family is like you think the crowns does
anything the crowns would weigh a lot
because they do have you guys ever worn
a crown they look heavy they look heavy
do you think they ever take photos or
he's like cupping the forearm or the
other
how do you think the voting works that's
a prom King smile though [__] you dude
that's a prompting smile I'll beat you
up dude
hey man shut up dude
I just had no idea we had Pasadena
monarchy in the room
like a commoner for so long from Royal
to Royal
okay let's talk about Geo huh
I almost forget he could like kill
people if he wanted to he could whoop
everyone's ass in here I know I forget
that's not that's not a cool thing to
bring up either
what do you mean you just you're a
freaking 80s horror flick you're
freaking the prom King killer
that's a terrible and guess what nobody
saw that movie nobody wanted to watch
that movie dude I don't know because it
started because it had an Asian lead
everybody want to watch Michael or Jason
not believable
um I got that idea because your wife
Tiff wrote that she sometimes I forget
this guy could beat everyone up that's
dumb though she's wrong yeah because
there's a lot of people because look
there's a lot of people like uh that are
like large size that would smash me like
a little bit no way way to promote your
career buddy keep it going with the
marketing willing to lose clients over
this yeah you're gonna die on that it's
the truth
of Nick whooping my ass what belt color
are you I wasn't just fun Brown how many
stripes in the brown though uh I think I
have one no well you got your stripe now
that's so fast did I put it on myself
maybe next time
who knows
the next time you
need to joke it's a 20 minute mark this
is where we turn off the camera
jacking off two dudes or thumbs down
which one is it
foreign